oh it's you you're gonna get me in
trouble doc did something cuz you me I
wish someone wanted to hear me other
than you
[Music]
I know I'm not supposed to love music no
music no music but my great-grandma
Coco's father was the greatest musician
of all time ernesto de la cruz one day
he left with his guitar and never
returned my family thinks music is a
curse great-great-grandfather none of
them understand me I'm supposed to play
music all right this is you're really
out there agents at the Department of
family reunions are available again you
hear
I know your great-grandpa I'll get you
to him what are you doing skeleton no
skeletons don't walk like that
how you walk no I go there's no one left
in the living world who remembers you
you disappear from this world but you
can change that we've gotta find my
freakish grandpa you've got a do it by
Sunrise what happens at sunrise you'll
be stuck here forever
Brad
[Applause]
[Music]
never forget how much your family loves
you
it's almost sunrise one cannot deny who
one is meant to be
[Music]
it doesn't have any hair and I don't
have a nose and here we are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they're setting up for tonight the music
competition for dia de Muertos you want
to be like your hero you should sign up
huh my family would freak look if you're
too scared then well have fun making
shoes come on what did a cruise always
say seize your moment show me what you
got muchacho
I'll be your first audience I know your
tricks mariachi what did he say to you
he was just showing me his guitar shame
on you you keep away from him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she's in the chosen you're all really
out there thought we weren't I don't
know I'd have been one of those made up
thinks that atop still kids like
vitamins Miguel
vitamins are a real thing for long
thinking maybe they could be I will eat
around the house just like mama Imelda
did
no music gone music I think only family
in Mexico who hates music and my family
is fine with them but me be back by
lunch I'm not like the rest of my family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no photo and a friends are no crossing
the beach you know what I'm just gonna
zip right over you don't even know
[Music]
fine okay who cares dump our grits
I don't know what I do if it's you you
you are that boy that the one who came
from the land of the living
Oh anyone has been talking about why
have you come here I'm again your your
great-great grandson I have a
great-great grandson
every year grandkids cousins
pretty much everyone gets together even
grandma I tell her pretty much
everything I used to like this but never
faster
eat your food cat some more
I mean see that's what I thought you
said the intervals windows has begun
it's the one night of the year
our ancestors can come visit us I
thought I might've been one of those
made up things because I was just a
night is about family
I'm not like the rest of my family
there's something that makes me
different great-great-grandfather I want
to be a musician just like you all right
I'm sorry
welcome to the land of your Hands's
regale we're your family
just Ellison's your eyes
[Music]
gotta get home before sunrise or you'll
be stuck forever oh come on
[Music]
it's so time
you my boy are meant to be a musician I
must follow my heart
[Music]
I am trying to save your life by skew-t
me game something snapped at more than
you think
sorry
we may have our differences but
nothing's more important than family
I'm proud we're family
[Music]
oh wait you go it's just bunting never
named a street dog they'll follow you
forever now go get my shoe Epic's our
research is crucial to our storytelling
and with Koko we have to visit a
beautiful country of Mexico this movie
you wanted to all be rooted in actual
places and actual people so it was
really important to us to see kind of
the breadth of Mexico and how many
different cultures and traditions there
are we visited big cities and little
towns multi-generational family
businesses of shoemakers for art for
story and characters it was just so
informative we were experiencing the
colors and the smells and the sights and
this incredible food from all the
beautiful architecture papel picado ala
brijes all of that is brought into the
film and all these different ways and
those early research trips not only
inspired the look but they inspired the
story and the importance of family do
you mind
we learned so much from remembering
family where you come from no music were
you going and as the story came together
we realized the movie was gonna be about
music as much as it's about family
we wanted the score to feel like it was
born out of this world so that meant
using a lot of instruments indigenous to
Mexico and it's been great to have
Jermaine Franco and Camila go down and
record New Mexico City we had over 50
musicians playing all different styles
and esta norteña pero choice Maria it
was fantastic Showtime Jamaica we had la
creme de la creme of Mexican talent
which helped showcase the sonic
landscape that Mexico has we shot a lot
of reference footage so the animators
can make every chord and every little
subtle bit of playing accurate I think
that's pretty amazing they put so much
work and feeling into the songs it makes
you wanna cope not so bad yourself girl
Rita
it was very pleasing astonished to see
the amount of preparation that directly
have begin to develop everything the
music the color the story the characters
that's why big star films are so amazing
they are films that will last forever I
feel incredibly fortunate to have spent
time with all the beautiful people that
we met it's a dream come true to be able
to put my own family's experiences into
a film that's a specialist Coco I am so
excited to share this film with the
world
[Music]
[Music]
once every year our ancestors come back
to our world to see family and friends
no living person
has ever visited their world until now
[Music]
moving the
[Music]
you gotta stay with me boy
[Music]
you mind
me gain what is going on remind me how I
know you
they're your family
[Music]
we have to get you back home welcome
anything to declare
as a matter of fact yes
[Music]
[Music]
I have to sing I have to play the music
it's it's not just in me it is me when
life gets me down I play my guitar the
rest of the world may follow the rules
but I must follow my heart you know that
feeling like there's a song in the air
and it's playing just for you
[Music]
never underestimate the power of music
no one was going to hand me my future it
was up to me to reach for my dream grab
it tight and make it come true
[Applause]
all right moving there
[Music]
you guys stay with me boy know where we
are
this isn't a treason you're all really
out there
[Music]